[Music]
we have an update to a story we told you
about last week which highlights the
huge challenges facing companies and
employees during the pandemic
the wisconsin medical records software
company epic systems had told thousands
of its workers
they would have to return to the office
starting today despite objections
from hundreds of them but now after our
reporting and pressure from local public
health officials
epic is temporarily pushing back its
plans
consumer investigative correspondent
anna werner along with our reporting
partners clear health costs
have been looking into this story for
weeks and a good morning
good morning vlad since our story aired
last week we've heard from dozens of
epic employees
who say the company's decision to force
them back into the office
risks not only their health but the
communities now
local officials say epic employees
who've been working from home
remotely for months should stay home
epic planned to start bringing over 9
000 employees back to its campus in
phases beginning today
but dane county's top official executive
joe parisi says
that's a mistake we're all making
sacrifices during this pandemic and
while we would all like to
be together and be able to meet in
person we can't do that for a while and
epic
is going to have to adhere by the same
the same rules as everyone else
after our story ran last week the
regional public health department said
the same
on friday it sent epic this letter
citing complaints it's received about
the plan
noting it had previously warned epic the
plan might violate the department's
kovit 19 emergency order
that order told employers to limit staff
in offices
and facilitate remote work the
department went on to say that epic had
claimed
it was facilitating remote work by
requiring staff to work in the office
but allowing them to work alone in their
office
of that department officials wrote
epic's interpretation is incorrect
remote work does not include working in
the office
working remotely and working remotely
you know usually from home it doesn't
mean coming into the office
and working from an office does that
argument even pass
the common sense test with you well
it's it's it's something on which we
have a disagreement with
with epic in an email to employees this
weekend obtained by cbs news
epic said it was modifying its return to
work policy
and employees who were told to return as
of monday are no longer required to do
so
but the company still insists it will
bring its employees back
and is asking public health officials to
further review
and approve its plan saying our
intention is to be a model for others
for how to return to work safely epic
ceo judy faulkner explained the
company's reason to employees in an
email earlier in july
saying we are losing big time the
culture that made the company successful
we want to share transparently the plans
that are in place
but in a recording leaked to cbs news of
an online meeting july 22nd with
hundreds of epic managers
vice president of technical services
brett ream explained it
somewhat differently because we're not
going to infinitely allow people to
choose their own adventure on this stuff
that's always been true for people that
say i want to work remotely i want to do
other things
there are business considerations here
and as managers it's important you guys
keep some of those things in mind
and he said further everybody needs to
figure this out but i don't think epic
is an evil bad guy here
but it turns out some of the company's
own health care clients disagree with
epic's plan
in comments shared with cbs news from an
internal epic system
one described epic as falling short of
their responsibilities
when it comes to their own employees
another said
i hope epic leadership will admit it was
wrong and reverse
course some employees say they couldn't
agree more
it's not worth taking that risk when we
can do our jobs well from home
well epic says it believes it is
complying with regulations at that
employee safety is a priority
they've also hired a doctor and they're
consulting with experts
and for employees who do choose to
return this week they've told them they
can do so gradually
on more flexible schedules anthony it's
good to hear
anna because that definition of remote
working alone in your office is a very
generous definition of remote in fact
i'm an english major it doesn't work i
don't think thanks